A Tribute to Carrie Fisher
Princess, you were one of a kind.
You lit up my childhood with your fearless mind
You're more than a pretty face, you were born to be wild!
Though the darkness it awaits you, you will never be defiled
Oh Leia (aaaaaaa-aaaaaa)
Your bravery, it stays reflected in those
Who shared with you your story and then watched it unfold
General, your dedication inspires
Born of royalty but hard work's what made us admire you
Oh Leia (aaaaaaa-aaaaaa)
I thank you, for sharing your hope with me
You'll never know your impact spread through more than one
Gaaaaalaaaaxyyyyy
Oh Leia (aaaa-aaa) Oh Leia (aaaaa)
Princess, oh you were one of a kind
Jedi powers m8 (init)
Hide-n-Seek powers
*SLURP HIDE*
I am one with the force
The force is with me
and I'm one with the force
The force with me
I'm one with the force
boop